( intro music )
I am in the jungle.
And I have absolutely no
experience in South America.
I've never set foot there.
So, I went in the
Amazon to look at
a specific community
in Bolivia.
And more specifically
in a settlement
called Anachere.
We went to
look at the Tsimané.
And the Tsimané, they
are about 2,500 people
living in the Amazon.
We went up river for about
two days in dug-out canoes.
After, you know, two-three days
flights, buses, cars, whatever.
We follow the
Maniqui River right here
which is a tributary
of the Amazon.
And eventually after
two days we got here.
This is the Nate family
welcoming us with SpongeBob.
- You see SpongeBob?
- ( audience laughter )
They live in small
family settlements.
They will have one
settlement here.
And then you need to walk for
15-20 minutes, half-an-hour
through the jungle, up the river
to reach another settlement.
And you know it's
very dense jungle.
They usually live in
these bamboo houses
with palm leaf roofs.
They used to be fulltime
hunter-gatherer,
only relying on hunting
and gathering.
Now, about 200 years ago
missionaries came there
and introduced them to
cultivation, to agriculture.
And so they grow a lot
of plantain and banana
a bit of rice as well.
And corn, which is originally
from that part of the world.
And they do
"slash and burn" agriculture.
They burn, they grow right
next to their settlement.
Also there is a
lot of plantain.
They eat so much plantain,
it's very dangerous
because, you know, you're like,
"I'm going to skid
on that, you know,
these banana skins and
stuff everywhere."
- ( audience laughter )
- And they take the plantain
and they throw it
directly in the fire.
Or they leave the skin on
or they shave it
there's all kinds of things.
Let's go for a little
drive down the river.
( speaking in Tsimané )
( sound of motor boat )
( insects buzzing )
( speaking in Tsimané )
( girl laughs )
Matthieu: And so, the family
gathers around,
often, the fireplace
like this.
This is the kitchen,
this is it.
You know, just an open space.
The youngsters will be around
and often the older men
they are going out hunting.
And everybody hopes for
some meat to come back.
But I am sitting there
and I see the two girls
like standing up and
they're just leaving.
I am like, "Whoa, where are
they are going?" You know.
I need to know anything
what's going on.
I don't know, they're just
going into the jungle.
I'm like, "dude,
but there's
like snakes and
all this stuff."
Yeah, but that is their home.
This is, for them, like going
around the block here.
And so they go out in the
jungle and they start foraging.
They're just, you
know, sitting there
and they just get up
at some point from camp
and just start walking
in the jungle
"let's go and find
something to bite on."
And found this palm tree and
started to eat palm fruit
which is full of good stuff.
And I looked around, I saw
these nice red berries.
I'm like,
"oh, this looks good."
They're like,
"you eat that, you're dead."
- I'm like okay.
- ( audience laughter )
So they know, I don't know.
They are incredibly intimate,
this really impressed me.
To see especially youngsters
go out like this.
It's really beautiful.
They often
go with dogs.
They have a lot of--
a few dogs
lying around that
they use for hunting.
And there's a lot of rodents or
you know, various animals
that live underground.
So they hunt it.
When the dogs find something,
they go with the machete
to try to clear out
the opening
to help the dog and
find the animal.
My room was in the
far right there.
I'll show you because
it's such a nice spot.
So, this is it,
this is my bedroom.
( audience laughter )
Cool stuff, there's a minibar.
Let me show you.
( audience laughter )
Matthieu: Oh!
( laughter )
Computer inside.
I was miserable in Bolivia.
I was really miserable.
There's so many mosquitoes,
it is incredibly hot.
I''m more like a, you know,
yak high-altitude type
- than monkey-jungle thing.
- ( audience laughter )
So, next day we go
down the river.
We want to go to next camp and
you know, what happened is...
This is the real
evolution of diet
when you start feeding
your camera with rice.
( audience laughter )
I fell, I fell in the river
my camera went fully
into the river, and...
I had a back-up,
thanks God for the back-ups,
so I could still shoot.
But it survived, so I put that
in a zip lock with rice.
So, if it ever happens
you all know the trick
with phone and stuff,
and it worked.
A week later, ten days later,
I switched it on, it worked.
You know we ended
up going up river.
I have changed my camera,
another camera, thanks God.
And we walked into
this beautiful scene
where this old
man, the older man
we saw him before
in his plantations
standing there same
again, I went back.
I love to go back to the same
spot because he is at ease.
You know he is washing,
he was stark naked
but you know, he's
seen me before
talked to him before,
he just lets me there.
And all this butterfly
flying around.
You can see the body of one
of the oldest men I met there
and who has been
hunter-gatherer all his life.
That would give
this kind of body.
He is over 70,
still very active,
still physical because
yeah, he has to walk every
day to feed himself.
You know, his kids
will help him.
But they go hunting.
And so I went hunting,
next day with his son.
They brought back food, finally.
They brought this
armadillo that
they cut up in
pieces and...
It tastes very much like
chicken, like anything.
They boil the meat.
They also had this coati, which
is a bit similar to badger.
They singe it in the
fire straight in.
Protein is very
important, protein.
This is the only way
for them to get it.
They don't get
animals every day.
Yeah, if they get that once
a week, they'll be happy.
And then
they do the gutting,
often the kids do the gutting.
The guys come back
from a long day
some time the whole
day in the jungle.
They are exhausted, they
arrive back to camp
they bring the food.
They sit down, the
women prepare fire
and then the kids
are given the task
to go and prepare the animal.
Everywhere, mostly
everywhere I went
it's often the kids
who do that task.
And so the pieces
of meat are taken,
there is plantain that
is shaven and boiled,
a bit of salt in there.
And they have this
kind of porridge.
Quite tasty result
in that plate there.
So, stomach full, you
know, feeling quite content
I returned and I knew
I was quite happy.
I knew what my next
destination was.